they actually arrested her after seeing
the evidence this is actually that
evidence came out listen honey I get
triggered by being punched like that's
my boundary can you please respect my
boundary
oh sorry no no I said I understand but
this is where now circumstantial factors
come come in you understand he's the
Nigerian guy he's in America black lives
matter why she's he's dating a Caucasian
woman he he knows that if he hits her
back he's gonna get down for it you
understand that is where now the old
circumstantial uh things happen but
she's the one abusing himself
because because she thought she was like
you cannot hit me you understand that's
what she's going with she's like you
cannot hit me you can do nothing to me
and I'll even call police on top of it
on top of that you understand that's
what she's thinking there when I saw
that what I was thinking is to all the
men out there that being beat by women
if there's a camera knock her the hell
out because I if he knew that there was
a camera there and after all that
resisting one bit slap and she would
have been down and as far as I'm
concerned it's all on camera
so I can understand now why people would
do things in front of cameras why they
want cameras up to protect themselves
because as far as I'm concerned if
you're getting abused and you're worried
about how it's going to see because
there's enough cameras I know it's
America but in the UK
slap for slap in it she's talking about
Mortal Kombat
I I would say this goes back to the
equity not equality like I said I would
say the same way that goes for guns
Amigos for a man if that is happening
what you do you get up and you leave as
a man you're strong enough to either
restrain her or to run away from her
because you're like me
just say like this when it's done you
run not fast I swear to God if my
brother was being hit like that from a
bit I swear to God knock that [ __ ] out
I swear to Jesus and it hits you just
run or just constraining you're gonna
have the hands like this
you shouldn't hit first you're not a
child you're a grown woman
it's one because one hit from a man can
knock around she'll die no but why does
he have to be considered but after he's
doing it it's an opportunity and this is
what I said Equity like a man this is
let's not forget the fact that a man is
way way physically stronger than him
that's why women expose myself
I get that I get that but this is what
I'm just about to say if that is the
case I think it's incredibly extremely
irresponsible to tell somebody to do
something like hit her back
because hey hey I did not say hit her
back I said knock that [ __ ] out
I'll tell you an example I'll tell you
an example she knows what she said no no
I'll give you an example yeah
um this has happened to you if like a
couple of guys that I know where they
get into a fight
and then they knocked the guy this is
knocking a guy out that's why I mean
five so it's more conditioned for these
things it knocks him out and actually he
gave him a brain hemorrhage and he died
the guy that he punched no I'm gonna
tell you if you're telling somebody to
knock her out so maybe it's already not
even conditioned to fight she's only
fighting you because she feels like she
can because you suppose listen do not
not people out what you do it's not it's
not you don't it doesn't mean if you got
first what if that first punch knocked
me out what if that first one give me a
concussion which one if she was the man
I'm the man I'm the woman the one man
okay Lucio the man I now hit you because
I you can't hit me bam what if that
first hit give you a concussion give all
right question cool so why does he only
have to count for me because oh if he
Nicks me back no bro you here so what
you wanted to land only because you
didn't land there as hard enough that's
your business you wanted to land it you
didn't land well you landed it so for me
first don't eat fast be expected to hit
back because it's instinct when someone
one comes for you what did you say I'll
come for you back I'll come for you back
when London everybody does that you're
gonna go from the back Nigerians
understand this intrinsically you know
so no one beat anybody you cannot be if
you cannot fight them don't fight in the
first place you're not your size don't
go Step Up think about it think about it
why do we why do we always take away the
consequence for women like why do we
like because this is what you're doing
you're saying the normal consequence if
you if girl girl boy boy is if you hit
someone even if they're stronger than
you you will get hit back you will
probably be knocked out but when it's
boy girl for some reason we get a a pass
why it's the same way that you wouldn't
put a woman and a man in a boxing ring
okay but if the woman signed up if the
woman said put me in this boxing ring I
would let her go if she said if she said
I am signing up volunteering to go box
let the [ __ ] go if she's playing boxes
okay dude you get it back I'll give you
I'll give you another example because
what we saw no more examples let me tell
you what you saw was it was shocking if
you want you can go and search for a lot
of these like NFL players and baseball
players and a lot of these men that have
abused their women left fights and see
what abuse from a man looks like okay
what are the strength levels are totally
different stuff no stop it my love what
what about those couples that the woman
is bigger than the man
where the woman is bigger than the man
the man likes big women it's fine she
likes them small it's fine thank you and
she feels like she can drag him like
he's one of her kids and I say the same
thing that I said boys if you're strong
restrainer and then walk away girls or
boys if you're not stronger bloody
protect yourself and run from the
situation
when the woman was hitting the man
you didn't say oh
why is it that if he has to hit her back
he has to restrain her why can't she
restrain herself why is it the man why
is why is he gotta take her slap but she
can't take his slap I don't care whether
this snap's bigger no that's what I'm
saying listen right I had when my son
was growing up in the neighborhood
everybody would raise their children do
not hit girls there was a particular
girl that used to go around
and pray on the boys friends of them she
will always hit them and I remember
coming home one day and there was a big
crowd outside where I lived
and I said what's going on and I can see
everybody rushing out oh it's your son
it's your son it's your son he's
fighting a girl and I thought my son
fighting a girl run downstairs like a
mad woman run downstairs I was like hang
on a minute start pulling off people off
my son pulling them off I said and who
who first
they said she hit him I said anybody
touched my son
I'm gonna break your arms I said I
because oh but Auntie Jen he's hitting a
girl I said you already told me that she
hit him first listen right I said Son go
get her he chase her all in somebody's
ass and the mother the woman in the
house said oh but Jennifer she's a girl
I said really did she eat your son no
Move Yourself she hit my son my son
turned around and the slap that she gave
him he gave her one
my son does kickboxing I didn't give a
[ __ ] one slap to five of us and you know
something when the boys come and say but
aren't Jane Aunt Jane I wanna educated
him do you know what next time I saw
that girl
she had some um she had plaster on her
foot
she messed with the wrong boys and the
boys from then on she never ever hit
another boy again you know why because
she learned then that
it changed now you hit somebody they're
gonna hit you back
[Music]
everywhere because after that she tried
taking me on
did you hit me she's just a moment
you know something right please
came for me right police came for me no
I didn't hear her tell a lie because she
was bigger than me she had my hands and
I head butted her and she dropped that's
why she felt she couldn't he said to me
um and what happened I said well think
about it why didn't I slap her because
she's bigger look at the size of her to
me and my head but I know what happened
her mom turned around and said whatever
Auntie Jenny does to my daughter
I agree with her I stand by her
where were these kids that are bigger
than you how about you this was in this
was in East time I knew him I don't
believe I think you live in harlemen
they know me as Auntie Jenny there and I
can't back up anything I said anything I
say because everybody knows Beverly can
you can you bring that girl back on a
show if you're out there Beverly
you're right there but as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible